one idea i have that i'd love to just
get your reaction to is if you go back
to 2008 2009 uh during 2008 there was a
liquidity crisis over the summer you
know gold sold off 30 or so the
government took about i don't know four
five six months to really kind of get
their heads around what should we do
here they ended up stepping in uh they
went ahead and started with you know
hundreds of billions which at the time
was you know absolutely massive monetary
bombs uh and then ultimately an asset
like gold hit the all-time high i think
it was in 2011. so kind of you know two
two and a half years later and so if you
take that as kind of a a
sequence of events that occurred over
let's say a three year time period we
basically got the exact same sequence of
events but it was packed into now rather
than three years maybe i don't know
three to six months in 2020 where we
started to see all time highs and
government intervention etc
is your belief or kind of your thought
process like we're just going to see
this happen faster and faster and faster
as we continue or do you think that the
kind of public health crisis and what we
saw in 2020 that might actually end up
being the outlier in terms of the speed
and the severity of a response in that
intervention because i think what's so
interesting about you is you actually
are not anti-intervention you're just
intervention when most needed or
intervention in an emergency scenario so
how do you think about uh that the speed
at which it has happened this last time
and is that going to be the norm or the
outlier moving forward and future kind
of crisis or emergencies
yeah you know this this is a really
tricky one um you know it's it
my view is that the fed is beholden to
markets at this point i mean that that's
it's just not my opinion based on fluff
it's just the evidence that we have
we have yet to see
a fed chairman
uh since
the global financial crisis that had the
backbone to actually
allow markets to have some pain i think
the problem is what i mentioned earlier
valuations have gotten bigger and bigger
and bigger so they're
really afraid of the monster that they
have
created um
the ecb and i'll just throw this out
you know last cycle before the covet
crisis was the largest expansion
in since the second world war things
were going well
but the ecb
didn't manage to raise rates at all i
mean they stayed negative through the
entire process
the last time they raised rates was
almost 11 years ago think about that
um and and so this was this whole
deflationary spiral that we've been in
and they've never managed to get
themselves out of that so i i keep
asking myself the the question of
efficacy
and
given the amount of money and the speed
that they went in they have shown
efficacy in terms of asset prices the
question is
what is the structural economy
underneath because whatever we saw last
year let's be very clear it's all
manufactured you know
yes you can have the most incredible
party if you throw 11 trillion dollars
combined fiscal monetary uh into a
system
unfortunately that just tells you
preciously
nothing about what the real economy
actually
looks like so this year will beginning
be what we see in the beginning of a
process my worry is that
for example i mentioned at the outset uh
retail sales 25 above trend if dallas
just if those just revert to pre-covert
trend you're already in a recession
right because you've you
you've jumped over the line so far that
just a reversal to base trend gets you
into major economic trouble just like
inflation
uh gdp growth is also relative right
so if you want to bring inflation down
you're going to end up with growth
coming down so that i have i have no
idea what they're going to do i don't
know what their backbone is in regards
to
letting the system flush itself out and
i don't think you can do it without a
recession you know i don't want to see a
recession but that's that's the risk you
either maintain the bubble indefinitely
which there's no history of that
happening
or you're gonna have to take the pain in
some shape or form and and and then when
the pain comes how much are they willing
to take before then repeating the cycle
all over again it's actually mad if you
think about it right
it's insane
it is the best way that i could think
about it